yo you're single now right I'm single
all the way okay I remember when you
broke up with your girl you definitely
sparked a debate we talked about it on
the radio show do you feel like
humans in general are meant to be with
people forever no okay
elaboration was about to say elaborate
because that was I mean I I kind of
appreciated like your uh transparency in
that situation it didn't get messy you
were just very much like hey look I had
a discussion and an agreement with my
lady I love her obviously but when that
agreement started to get kind of you
know violated or whatever like you know
it's not like you didn't tell her about
it you know what I'm saying I mean I
feel like everybody's had a survey
Purpose with whatever that is right on
life
life is a is a journey first and
foremost and um along that Journey
everything is temporary nothing is
permanent in life you know what I'm
saying not one thing is one of them
things that's just gonna last forever
right nothing's permanent but death to
the physical but even after the physical
death you're transformed into something
else because energy doesn't die right so
nothing is ever permanent so I feel like
a lot of people just come in my life to
to serve some type purpose for me to
learn something and all right once I
learn it it's ready to go on the next
Journey The Next Step what's next I
don't I don't ever feel I have somebody
in my life that's just always going to
be there because in the same sense like
it's just it's just over a period of
time things turn sour and things turn
sour because it's not meant to be held
on to Forever it's okay we did this we
did this okay now I feel like it's time
for me to let go and you to grow and for
me to let go and I I can grow so I can
get whatever we both benefited from you
at this time from each other and now we
kind of take what we took from the
relationship and move on yeah move on
yeah like that's that's how it would be
you know that's a part of Detachment
people people are missing Detachment in
everyday life
um you got to be able to detach from
things because if you don't it can hurt
you in the long run you know what I'm
saying would you
pretty much say that it'd be difficult
to Envision yourself ever being married
um I don't I don't see myself being
married not really
um marriage is a beautiful thing but uh
I don't see myself being married because
every married couple I talked to they're
not happy like everyone
um it depends like how long they've been
married but anybody I've talked to
that's like five years and over I asked
them about marriage they were like yeah
it's cool but don't do it like that's
the that's every married couple so like
I've just learned from that experience
I'm like I'm I'm not would you ever pull
the AC on and have like you know the
police little seven or eight wives just
you know that's what I like the whole
house full of wives yeah I mean it's a
village you know it'll help you build
what you're trying to accomplish like if
you have a lot of women that's around to
help you build what you're trying to con
accomplish you don't have attachment
issues a lot of things you're going to
be like another Nick Cannon in 10 years
I love kids I feel like my we hear the
population though listen I got a feeling
in 10 years every three weeks we're
gonna see Emily chop is expecting a new
baby and before we know it you're gonna
have 30 kids and that's a beautiful
it'll be see look this is a beautiful
thing and and you're gonna be miserable
because you're gonna have to babysit 28
of them
yo you know if you have over 10 to 12
kids you don't have to pay child support
that's a dub really yeah if you have if
you have over 10 to 12 kids you don't
have to in certain cities I'm not sure
that's true for any of them in certain
in certain cities that's true if it's
with one girl maybe I think it's
different women so if you have 10 kids
with 10 women they're all they're 10
women are [ __ ] from getting child
support off you yeah I mean but I might
be wrong but if you're looking for
someone to have 10 kids and not be there
for them yeah for sure yeah that's over
so you gotta take care of them but you
know I think that's the thing have you
met Nick Cannon yeah yeah my guy I've
been a while and out everything with
them you guys should have a little like
uh I feel like you guys are you know